après la manifestation d'hier près de
l'ambassade d'israël où des incidents
avaient opposé militants juifs et
militants pro palestiniens le mouvement
gif le betar a réuni ses sympathisants
près du siège de l'ol paie aujourd'hui à
distance séparés par la police
les pro palestiniens il y a eu quelques
accrochages des petits palestiniens
accueillis en france à l'invitation de
l'association france palestine
un premier groupe de 87 enfants est
arrivé aujourd'hui à paris michel perron
ses enfants vous avez déjà vu sur vos
écrans il vivait il ya encore quelques
semaines sous les bombes et les tirs
automatiques de beyrouth ouest et u du
caissier traditionnels ils étaient 87 à
débarquer aujourd'hui à l'aéroport
charles de gaulle où il était notamment
accueilli par monsieur ibrahim sousse
porte parole de l'ump en france à
l'invitation de neuf municipalités il
fasse moins si un mois dans différents
centres de vin quartier qui viennent de
sabra et chatila en fait mais qui sont
qu'ils ont quittée
de l'iman avec l'évacuation dans sa
liste
dans ce groupe ils sont nombreux à avoir
perdu un ou plusieurs parents au cours
des combats ou sous les bombes
de par mes parents sont morts at elle
des affaires
merci et j'ai parmi mes proches il ya ma
grand mère qui est à l'heure actuelle à
sabra et j'ai d'autres proches à chatila
également 40 autres enfants doivent les
rejoindre dans deux jours et
l'association france palestine qui est à
l'origine de cette invitation espère
poursuivre cette expérience avec
d'autres municipalités